das habe ich auch noch kaffee
verschüttet deine pflege ist der gute
kommen boden gelandet bin ich mir genau
passiert kleine rohde
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
in dem ihr die tatsache dass itv
existiert dadurch erträglicher machen
dass wir uns darüber lustig machen und
das habe ich mich ein paar von euch eine
ganz spezielle hilfe folge mit seiner
reaktion darauf wünschte diese folge
heißt terror oma ich muss hier raus wie
start hatte ich mir kurz vor der zeit
geben das sich gestern auf der
geburtstagsparty von rewe war und nicht
komplett aus dem leben geschafft habe
sollte ich also im zuge dieses videos
aussehen wie ein zombie oder den
einsamen ihren außer zu haben wisst ihr
woran es liegt jetzt ok also das ist
schon mal die patienten um die es geht
ich muss irgendwie sagen ich könnte euch
nochmal das schnell eigentlich finde die
frau sieht irgendwie aus wie ein vogel
oder haben sie schon mal gesagt dass der
mensch aus wie ein vogel aber ich finde
die sieht aus wie ein vogel diese oma
ich weiß nicht was für ein vogel aber
wir kriegen auch auf jeden fall schon
mal eine erste idee davon worum es gehen
könnte ein junger mensch vielleicht ihre
enkelin oder so kniet auf dem boden und
wird zur post aber geknechtete während
sie sich im café rezept auch entspannt
[Applaus]
der charmante junge oder auch nicht mehr
ganz so junge dame ich muss sagen dass
ich bisschen von denen omas ab die ich
in meinem leben persönlich kennengelernt
habe so die omas in meinem leben war
immer so schön dass du wieder da bist
hier hast du drei kilo schokolade frist
ist erstmal nicht rein damit du schön
fett wirst ja also auch der sympathie
punkte skala sport diese oma tatsächlich
sehr gut muss man sagen sie zeichnen
sich dadurch aus
ihrer jungen enkelin gegenüber sehr
beleidigend ist sie fertig macht sie
vernichtet und dann natürlich auch noch
das ist wirklich das aller beste was man
machen kann auch noch verstorbene
familienmitglieder mit in diese ganze
rechnung reinbringt da ist er wirklich
am ende des tages dafür gesorgt dass die
enkelin komplett depressiv was der
veranstaltung rausgeht nein leider
deswegen auch so vorgegangen weil sie es
nicht ertragen kann
da muss ich ja auch zustimmen leute ich
krieg auch wirklich mit ihr alter die
oma einfach eine entspannte coole frau
die oma schreit auch noch die ganze zeit
voll angenehm was macht ihr entwickeln
hofft auf den knien auf dem boden herum
und putzt alter was soll die scheiße
denn der welt direkt aggressiv und so
weiter macht dann gut also wenn man
möglicherweise leicht unterschiedlicher
mensch ist so wie diese oma und dann
sagt okay also wenn du genau das jetzt
weiter machst dann sterbe ich als
nächstes machen die macht dann dreimal
so sollte du wirst sehen nur zurück
kaufte ich aber sauber warum ich das
auch heute kennt ihr das noch dieses
kind wird ein return mit viel liebe so
die gleichen tonlage heute noch mal
fertig werden dann staubt mal mit ihm
die nussknacker figuren ab und der
kühlschrank ist leer
wer zum wohle der allgemeinheit neue
front aber zum wohl der allgemeinheit
wäre das wahrscheinlich schon nicht
schlecht wenn du den hungertod sterben
würde ist aber so oder so also wirklich
eine sehr sehr sympathische ohne oma hat
natürlich jeder gerne einfach eine
direkte ausgeburt der hölle habe ich
auch noch das
nicht passiert kleine rote muss sagen
heute ist fällt wirklich schwer diese
folge anzuschauen einfach weil diese
frau hat die aufnahmen flora heißt es
ist wirklich schwer dieser frau
zuzuhören flora zu zuhören weil sie
einfach in jede mutter gefügten saß
schreibbüro kannst du bitte bitte sagt
nur einsatz in der normalen tonlage ok
ok schade leute für alle die an der
schule so wie ich die hoffnung hatten
dass die alte vielleicht mal kurz mal
umkippt nach der ganzen schweiz gerade
gerade eben und fängt einfach ich kann
keinen schlaganfall hast du so was das
wären wir natürlich keinen wünschen
auffällig zu einer kurzen macht einfach
auf entspannt soll
sie hat ja auch wirklich jetzt
stundenlang durch geschrieben das kann
in dem alter es kann eigentlich gar
nicht gehen ja aber stattdessen dass sie
mal einfach sich lang macht ne direkt
weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nächste szene sie es bei ihrem job in
der tankstelle keine ahnung arbeitet ein
paar kunden ab kommt einfach
juli an macht doch sein handy musik und
ein paar pappschilder raus bist du jetzt
ein antrag machen
in der tankstelle oder wie das
gewissenlose mit der junge
du hast dich vom ersten moment
verzaubern
auch wenn ich schon oft nein gesagt hast
ist die hoffnung nicht auf die hoffnung
worauf mich auf vorübergehen ihr kollege
worüber reden wir
willst du mit der alten gehen willst ja
einfach nur oder willst du heiraten so
oder so egal was es ist davon
ich weiß nicht also wenn sie schon ein
paar mal nein gesagt hat wie ist ja
augenscheinlich der fall ist hat sich
wahrscheinlich wirklich kein bock so
vielleicht einfach macht irgendwas
anderes mit der beleben als stadt dort
pappschilder einzuschleppen ja leute mal
wieder klassische situation muss man an
der stelle wenn mal ein kompliment
aussprechen eine rtl 2 da habt ihr
wirklich einfach die alltagssituation
und das alltagsleben von jungen menschen
wirklich auf den kopf getroffen ich muss
euch gewinnt immer öfter andere dass die
skripte für die seelen wir folgen
einfach von so 50-jährigen geschrieben
werden oder so keine als ich meine wer
in unserer generation würde auf die idee
kommt dass jemand pappschilder eine
tankstelle einstelliger betrag einfach
erfasst und dann nicht und nicht mal
musste die dms hrm einzuleiten nicht in
die tankstelle
ich habe ihn nach seinen
lieblingsstücken ich habe es wegen
ergänzen
[Gelächter]
egal ob die angeblich so gerade wissen
doch komisch sagt so jetzt geh aus mit
mir waren
ich war mal wie auch ich auch
sei es mit der ausgleich guckt mal an
die betriebliche durchschnitt sogar mit
einigen gemeinden pappschilder in diesem
fall kapital stelle ja okay man auch
beim handy sollte romantische musik an
alles nur damit du endlich mehr aus was
soll ich noch mal boxen jetzt geht es
darum dass sich wieder über irgendwas
kochen bus und ja wie das ausgeht kann
man sich auch schon denken ja das war
schon mal und jetzt wo du ansprichst es
geht hat sich noch weiter ich kann da
noch so ein paar blausäure kapseln
wollte es erst mal ein bisschen so zu
unterbinden dass du quasi ersten
bauschmerzen axt und dann später wenn
sich die katze in der letzten zeit und
dann kommen wir den löffel abgibt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit könig das ist derzeit korrekt aber
vielleicht gibt es den tieren was den
ganzen tag nur klärt und allen auf den
sack geht das bist du chinesin rettet
der goalie aus der tankstelle ist jetzt
tatsächlich zum welt vorbei gekommen
ein schönes haben sie arbeiten sie
gartenhaus was ein schönes haus haben
sie arbeiten sie gerne im haus habe also
arbeiten sie als gaerte also als
reitgerte ja also wir wissen dieses ding
ist längst teil wo ist mein pferd
schlägt damit die machen was man ihnen
sagt arbeiten sie als das im haus oder
arbeiten sie als als als mistgabel immer
auf eine schöne fahrers haben sie
arbeiten sie wehrte im haus
ich arbeite nicht als gaerte im haus
alter gefährte wasserkontakt in gerthe
mit hausarbeiten schmeckt ihnen der
kuchen mir schmeckt der großartigen ich
bin auch lecker
auch hier 0 sind alter sie kaut einfach
die ganze zeit schon auf dem kuchen also
man sieht dass er sie kaufte er die
ganze zeit und sie hat schon gute mund
und bei der elften gabe vom
kuchenverkauf aha momente da schmeckt
mir überhaupt nicht
die zugabe davor habe ich da weiß nie
gehörte er wird sich aber gerade
weitergeht gibt ich würde euch wirklich
noch gerne mehr erzählen andere szenen
als dieser folge zeigen aber es passiert
wirklich nicht mehr
es geht einfach so weiter und die folge
endet einfach wieder abrupt damit dass
sie halten bei diesen am tisch sitzen
immer noch um die oman zeit um so wie
die ganze zeit also hatte ich fürchte
wir können auch nicht mehr so viel
machen schreibt mir gerne die kommentare
was sie von dieser zauberhaften dame und
von dieser wunderbaren sendung dieses
mal gehalten habt ihr kriegt hier ein
für euch vorgeschlagen könnte meinen
gerade abonnieren ich danke euch fürs
zuschauen leute und weil jetzt mal zu
sehen endlich etwas gegen diesen scheiß
kater zu machen macht's gut